prinz charles und herzogin camilla zu
besuch in münchen
das royale ehepaar wurde am
donnerstagmittag von bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder und
seiner frau karin empfang auf einem rund
100 meter langen roten teppich kam es zu
zahlreichen begegnungen mit ihren fans
nach berlin und leipzig ist münchen die
letzte station ihrer deutschlandreise in
der bayerischen landeshauptstadt will
sich der ewige thronfolger über bio
wirtschaft und grüne technologien
informieren
zunächst kehrte das paar aber im
hofbräuhaus 1
dort tanzte teils auch mit anderen damen
zum schluss gab es bayerisches bier und
frische brezeln für den 70-jährigen
sicherlich nicht das erste mal einem
medienbericht zufolge soll er bereits
mehr als 30 mal in deutschland gewesen
seien teilweise privat